pour purger actuellement une peine de 15
ans pour vol à main armée oui madame
l'amour de ma vie a dit
les médecins lui donnent un an
je vais vous supplier de me libérer donc
je puisse donner à nîmes avait tué volé
je regrette tellement
c'est ça ouais je n'irai 15 ans à cause
de mauvaises fréquentations
on va dire oui je préférerais on va dire
oui monsieur oui monsieur
[Musique]
ils ont que j'ai un petit extra de
proposer
mais si je refuse ça me ferait de la
peine forcément un honnête homme comme
toi ça devrait pas avoir du mal à
joindre les deux bouts
j'avais dit mais il vraiment beaucoup de
chance moi aussi jamais
mon coursier transporter un demi million
$ et il n'est jamais arrivé à
destination
mais si vous envisagez de pouvoir danser
à nouveau avec votre cher et tendre
je vous conseille de vous poser ici avec
mes cinq cent mille dollars vous n'avez
aucune idée de quoi vous mettez les
pieds
vous pousser un homme désespéré allé un
peu trop loin a dit calme du cabri et
pour gueule rien man m'arrive et vous
priez pour gabriel m'arrive à moi ça
vient on sait parfaitement que c'est pas
n'importe quelle femme qui supporterait
ce genre de vie
plutôt mourir que de passer notre
dernière année à deux en cavale à
surveiller dans l'ariège je vais
[Musique]